well
as most people understand it virtual
reality is a technology for experiencing
worlds which don't really exist
worlds which are sustained
by electronic means as a
virtual illusion
and
do you find this a particularly
interesting
facet for you to pursue
or is this enough to just come and
explore it to this degree
no no uh
virtual reality hasn't even reached the
level of the wright brothers flyer at
this stage
my interest in it is as a vehicle for
exploring the imagination and then being
able to take other people along on the
trip
this is the promise that virtual reality
holds out but as yet it's an extremely
unfulfilled promise
what facet have you been interested in
particularly at this stage
well my
interest is in slaving virtual realities
to language to make language something
which is visually beheld
i don't see virtual reality as an
entertainment device so much as a way of
perfecting the project of human
communication
and the way to do this is to take
the
low
bandwidth signal represented by small
mouth noises and turn it in to a virtual
topology of intentionality make meaning
something that people see rather than
hear this is what virtual reality holds
out in my mind that's what i'm
interested in
tell me um you are known for your time
wave theory would you have you seen any
major
uh
well
no i can't really pinpoint it on the
timeline because one of the interesting
things about virtual reality is it's not
a discovery in the ordinary sense like
the discovery of radium or radio it's an
integration of already existing
technologies
the only thing new in virtual reality is
the glove
but the integration of computers
television
eye goggles and so forth so what will
allow virtual reality to develop fairly
rapidly i think is the fact that no new
technologies are necessary
the other thing which gives virtual
reality a tremendous advantage as an
evolving or developing technology is the
fact that the human
optical
system the human information processing
system in the brain is very forgiving of
the kinds of errors
and
smudgy fuzziness that we get in these
early vr virtual reality situations so
it's almost as though our physiology
makes virtual reality our destiny
i um experienced that hardware obviously
this is a tremendous threshold to cross
a reality built for two can be built for
two million
the the difficulty is going from one to
new type of technology as a threat or
boon to
the whole natural
world
well
virtual reality is not really defined
there are ways to think about it where
it seems very destructive of the natural
world as a kind of super television and
a super media addiction
on the other hand there is talk of
using navigation satellites to
create a world where all advertising
would be in virtual reality
my ordinary field of involvement is with
psychedelic plants and shamanism and
since that is
the original virtual reality tradition
in other words
uh the shaman
makes a voyage into a virtual reality
which is validated by mythology but
which only he can see and experience in
his trance well i think that kind of
archaic notion of virtual reality has to
be firmly in front of us as we design
this new technology or it will simply be
another force for our dehumanization
which is the last thing
one of the um
or it will turn itself inside out or we
will be able to look back at the future
how
does virtual reality make that interface
do you think do we or do we
play into
yeah i think so because all these
apocalyptic scenarios or millenarian
scenarios that you sketched out have as
their common denominator that we as a
species are going to live in the
imagination
the imagination is the
future frontier for humanity so
it may be a combination of drugs
techniques
technologies
attitude shifts
linguistic redesign of our
language assumptions all of this may be
necessary to propel us into a world
whose rules are not the laws of physics
but the laws of the human imagination i
think that's what excites the people
here who really care about this is the
belief that this is going to be a tool
for communication and art
and understanding among people
and excitement
excitement breeds excitement that's
right
well this is the first non-lethal
technology with a major commercial
potential that we've seen in the united
states in a long long time
and it's very exciting
no i think the united states is largely
irrelevant to the development of this
technology because this country is
bankrupt morally spiritually
economically this will all be developed
in germany in
japan possibly
other people will have a role to play
but i think american technology will be
largely imitative in spite of the fact
that we have an early lead
early leads seem to be something we
usually have only to squander when the
race gets
hot already there's much going back and
forth
over this particular topic maybe it's
possible to unify everyone around this
game
well i think unifying is what this
technology holds out as an ultimate
possibility although on what scale what
time scale this unity will arrive is
hard to say
what an event like this is is a meme
shower
we're having a shower for the new meme
and the new meme is this whole virtual
reality interactive technology complex
what people can do
is carry the meme back into their
communities and their affinity groups
and correctly represented
you know a few years ago these same
people who were here tonight many of
them were attending
conferences on space colonization
this has not been mentioned for years
it's dead in the water the reason is it
was a technology oversold too quickly
there's nothing worse for a technology
than to be premature
and
timing is everything in the launching of
a new system
so
it would be very good for this community
to learn from the examples of space
colonization perhaps even psychedelic
drugs that may be a different issue but
it was also a situation where many
people's hopes clustered around
something as being the the kernel of the
pearl of a new social order
and then it was not able to
deliver so this is the challenge of
virtual reality how many more of these
opportunities will we have before famine
madness overpopulation and stupidity
sweep over us
we might say virtual reality is
the last straw
[Music]
right now
before you go on to the stage
i think that the technical community
deserves a huge amount of credit for
creating virtual reality
but that the moment has now come to
bring in
the playwrights the artists the
designers the architects have already
been involved but people in the arts
need both to be informed that this is
going on and they have to bring their
insights into this community otherwise
as one of the speakers said tonight
we're in danger of seeing it just be
turned into three-dimensional computer
games
[Music]
my pleasure as well my dear always nice
to talk to you
great thanks very much
[Music]
you